is Aquaman and the lost kingdom going to
be ready by its December 2023 release
date considering how many times it's
been re-shot we'd certainly hope so with
the cancellation of bad girl an
uncertain future following the hiring of
James Gunn and Peter saffron as co-heads
of DC Studios and a year-long string of
bombs in the record books for 2023 there
are only two more films for fans to look
forward to before Gunn leads a reboot of
the universe with Superman Legacy in
2025. aside from Blue Beetle which
premieres on August 18th there's Aquaman
in the lost kingdom and right now it's
set to be a major Christmas season tent
pool for the studio on December 20th the
production of Aquaman in the lost
kingdom has been fraught with shake-ups
which is ultimately resulted in three
sets of reshoots from executive changes
to differing expectations from DC's
higher ups to negative test screenings
there have been a number of delays that
have resulted in the film's release
being pushed back from December 2022 to
December 2023 but a fresh set of
reshoots have the studio optimistic that
things might turn out well after all
times are changing to support the tabs
are changing Aquaman in the lost kingdom
has been in the works for so long that
it has managed to survive through three
regime changes at DC Studios naturally
that means each set of execs wanted
different things from the property the
sequel was greenlit by Toby Emrick
former head of the Warner Brothers film
department while principal shooting was
overseen by Walter Hamada who served as
the head of DC films under emmerich both
men departed as the film was undergoing
test screenings those test screenings
resulted in two sets of reshoots
greenlit by Emrick and Hamada's
Replacements Michael Deluca and Pamela
Abdi as well as new Warner Brothers
Discovery CEO David zazlov The Hollywood
Reporter noted that Abdi in particular
was Hands-On with the sequel and oversaw
a new cut however her version did even
worse with test audiences than the
Hamada one when James Gunn and Peter
saffron entered the picture a third set
of reshoots were greenlit which spanned
five days and apparently pleased all
involved unsurprisingly each set of
Executives wanted something unique from
the material that each previous cut
didn't have for instance Amada wanted to
use Michael Keaton's version of Bruce
Wayne not just in the second Aquaman
film but across DC's slate of movies as
a sort of guide and leader for the
younger generation of Heroes
Batman what do we do we try not to die
unfortunately the ever-shifting
quicksand of DC films resulted in a
skewed Timeline under the Michael Deluca
and Pamela Abdi regime reshoots
involving Ben Affleck's take on Batman
were filmed to make it more harmonious
with its place in the extended DC World
however it appears that none of this
material will make it into the final
version of the film as James Gunn and
Peter saffron didn't want to build a
story promising the continuation of a
universe that's set to be officially
abandoned this world must die while that
means a lot of the film's original plot
has been changed at least those missing
moments might make for fun deleted
scenes but when you add these internal
conflicts to the burden already
shouldered by overworked VFX houses you
end up with a movie that keeps getting
pushed back from its original debut date
Aquaman in the lost kingdom has also
been shaped by repeated sets of test
screenings several of these screenings
have resulted in audience displeasure
with story Clarity being an ongoing
concern this sent the show's producers
and Executives back to the drawing board
to bring the best possible man sequel to
life the end result is several cuts of
the film making their way into the
editing process the magazine declared
that the latest set of reshoots greenlit
by James Gunn and Peter saffron went
extremely well reportedly the reshoots
only took four days instead of the five
scheduled and seemed to have finally
gelled the film into what Warner
Brothers wants it to be there is no word
as to what's been changed in the Final
Cut of the movie but at least this
winter DC fans will finally get to find
out what all the fuss was about